[موسيقى]
آه ، معكرونة ، انتظر شيئًا ما ليس صحيحًا
عكس الاتجاه قليلاً ، حسناً ،
قشدة مخفوقة
غريبة بعض الشيء للحصول على ذلك مع السباغيتي ،
لكن دعنا نذهب معها
معكرونة ما هي الآيس كريم آه
إنه آيس كريم الجميع
صلصة الفراولة والشوكولاتة البيضاء
أوه نعم آيس كريم معكرونة ،
شكرًا  أنت لمن جاء مع
مذنب إسبنداريو فونتانيلا
من الجليد ، واو
حسنًا ، دعني أحصل على هذه المعكرونة
والجيلاتي
اثنين من الأطعمة الإيطالية الشهيرة التي
اصطدمت بشكل جميل في
ألمانيا ، ولكن قبل أن
يغضب جميع مشاهدينا الإيطاليين
علينا ، يجب أن نشرح ذلك  كان
جد داريو الإيطالي هو
الذي بدأ هوس العائلة بالآيس كريم ،
لكن كان داريو هو الذي
غير العالم الذي
أعلم أن هذه
[موسيقى]
بدأت العائلة في بيع الاختراع الجديد
من محل الآيس كريم الخاص بهم ،
وبصرف النظر عن جعل الأطفال يبكون ،
أثبت الطبق  شعبية في
الواقع قد تكون وسيلة
معكرونة
بخسة قد دفعه اختراعه إلى
شهرة
الآيس كريم  الشيء الأكثر أهمية ليس
شهرة الآيس كريم ، الشيء المهم هو
متعة كل
الجليد في شكله من السباغيتي ،
فأنت تخبرني أنه أفزعني
قليلاً في بداية هذا
الفيديو
ولكني نوعًا ما  تريدها الآن
أنت